buckle up we start with great news
tonight game set match the repulsive
disgusting shift show circus is almost
over and finally we see the light at the
end of the tunnel at this hour very good
sources are telling me that the Schumer
ship sham show is circling the drain
can't come soon enough nothing is
definite but it appears Senate Majority
Leader McConnell now has the votes to
block further witnesses and this whole
pointless charade could be wrapped up
hopefully Friday or Saturday of this
week earlier today Colorado senator Cory
Gardner announced that he will vote
against new witnesses saying he didn't
need to hear from an eighteenth witness
to render a verdict john bolton is now
officially out of the equation being
needed as a witness I'll explain in a
minute now Republicans likely need just
one more vote put an end to the madness
once and for all and to be honest well
it could come from either side of the
aisle there is now high anxiety inside
the Democratic Party tonight Fox
news.com reporting that any future
witness agreement would be subject to a
package deal in other words Bolton gets
hold in we'll tell you why that doesn't
that's no longer necessary in a minute
so will two key members of let's say the
Biden syndicate quid pro quo Joe zero
experience hunter and as we have
documented so many times at a bare
minimum there's a serious appearance of
impropriety we went through all the laws
that well seemed to fit in this case
with the Biden's all felonies the
president remember has a sworn
constitutional duty to faithfully
execute the laws of this land and that's
why he was rightly concerned not only
about Ukrainian election interference
separate and apart from Russian
interference which Devin Nunez warned
about but he's also rightly concerned
about quid and pro and quo Joe and not
say oh like Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders who happens to be leading in
both Iowa and New Hampshire let me sum
it up for you one more time this thing's
over it's finished everything else will
be a mere formality now we know how this
will
the president will be acquitted and
thankfully in 279 days we will have an
election in this country as a matter of
fact we have now actually heard from
what the Democrats thought would be
their latest star witness moments ago
the president tweeted out these words
game over along with the words he sent
out a video 20:19 John Bolton praising
the president's phone call yes the
wanting question with Ukraine let's take
a look I will be meeting president
zalenski he and president Trump have
already spoken twice President called to
congratulate president Solinsky on his
election and then on his success in the
parliamentary election they were very
warm and cordial calls we're hoping that
they'll be able to meet in Warsaw and
have a few minutes together because the
success of Ukraine maintaining its
freedom its system of representative
government a free market economy free of
corruption and dealing with the problems
of the Donbass and the Crimea are high
priorities here obviously but high
priorities for the United States as well
sounds almost verbatim the president's
description of the call what we all read
with the transcript did you hear any
quit or prose or quos like Joe there did
you hear any dire warnings about
misconduct or abuse of power did you
hear any complaints or consternation at
all the answer is no that brings me to
Mitt Romney tonight as I said last night
I fought hard as many of you did he
would have been the better candidate and
I think we were proven right if he won
his election in 2012 I defended him
against the left smears I did it because
it was the right thing to do he was the
better candidate they called him a
racist they called them a sexist they
called them a misogynist they accused
him of abusing animals even lie smears
and even cutting some kids hair MIT
Romney said earlier in the week that he
would likely want to hear from John
Bolton well we have now heard everything
we need to hear from John Bolton in his
own words and even if the president had
privately said that he wanted Ukraine to
do a
or B or C for the aid there are four
facts Jim Jordan reminds us every time
they'll never change no linkage between
aid and investigations during the phone
call aid was never mentioned during the
phone call but the issue of corruption
was brought up President was clearly
concerned it was top of mind we know
president szalinski repeatedly and
president Trump have both denied ever
any pressure in any way shape matter and
form no.1 in Ukraine even knew there was
a temporary pause on aid at the time of
the call along after the call and
Ukraine here's the important part did
they do anything did they take any
action to get the aid release none zero
nothing did they announce they would do
something nothing they announced nothing
never ever and they still got the money
so even if the president thought it even
if he said it maybe thinking about it
doesn't matter it's what he did senator
Romney I say to you tonight it is time
for you to put aside what is clearly a
personal disdain dislike for the
president and you need to do this for
the sake of the country and frankly for
your sworn duty to the Constitution of
the United States now forget about your
opinions about the president they're
irrelevant you need that document right
there you need to think about your
constitutional constitutional role in
duty as a senator remember the house and
the Constitution as the sole power to
impeach a president they did it now they
presented their very pathetically weak
case okay
I are asking 16 hours worth of questions
your duty the soul said it the sole role
of the Senate is to examine the evidence
render a verdict now you just heard from
John Bolton and keep in mind senator
Romney I know you represent the great
state of Utah take a look at this survey
put together by well he's one of the few
people I've know Matt Towery since the
Gingrich polling years and Matt Towery
was one of the few people that said it's
on video I've got a copy that Donald
Trump was gonna win not many pollsters
were saying this
68% he did a poll of Utah last night of
your constituents in Utah they want
president Trump acquitted 64% oppose
additional witnesses 60% would be less
likely to support
you if you vote to keep the charade
going and what can call for witnesses by
the way think about all those Democrats
that are asking you to trust them think
about who's begging for witnesses there
he is the compromised in this particular
case corrupt and we all know congenital
liar by the name of Adam Schiff
how could anyone in good conscience ever
trust what is really a pretty despicable
sociopath now shifts pants and pen on
fire for three consecutive years he's
lied about Russia Russia Russia
collusion collusion FISA he lied about
the FISA application and Ukraine phone
call he lied about the whistleblower and
he even lied more today in fact we just
got him red-handed today lying again
about the call transcript between the
president President Trump and President
Zielinski take a look I want you to do
me a favor though I want you to do an
investigation of MIT Romney do any of us
have any question that Barack Obama
would be impeached for that kind of
misconduct that's the parallel here any
light in his reports of the American
people and now we know because of the
Inspector General report he lied and
congressman Devin Nunez told the truth
bulk of information was the dirty
unverifiable dossier from Russia that
Hillary paid for we also knows the only
American that we know on tape thinking
he's talking to a Russian colluding to
get dirt on Donald Trump to use it an
election you know remember whoa what
what do you have compromising materials
what really what are they
pictures of naked to them what did
flattered mirror see them could we have
them that would be Adams chef now the
president didn't say by the way in the
transcript even though yeah Schiff had
to make that up too he didn't say do me
a favor
he said do us a favor he said in
relation to the United States and of
course we have Politico to Ukrainian
Court well they both determined there
was election interference by the
Ukrainians to help Hillary Clinton they
said it by the way interference that we
were all worked up about for three long
years foreign interference pull
go reports right there takes 22 minutes
to read it when it says 22 minutes but
naturally that was only one of many
lives today from the congenital liar now
this is pretty amazing you know one
truly bizarre example from earlier today
yep the congenital liar ship actually
doubled down on a lie that has
previously earned him four Pinocchios
from the liberal Washington Post for a
Democrat that's hard to get and despite
the mountain of evidence that shift
staff communicated with the fake
whistleblower from the get-go
well the congenital liar still claiming
he had no idea who the person is you
believe him because he's contradicted
him didn't they back and forth and back
again take a look first of all I don't
know who the whistleblower is I haven't
met them or communicated with them in
any way the conspiracy theory which I
think was outlined earlier that the
whistleblower colluded with the Intel
committee staff to hatch an impeachment
inquiry is a complete and total fiction
he first said that he said oh I should
have been more clear yeah there was
contact with my office and the
whistleblower now he's saying it didn't
happen a complete total fiction when
even the liberal Washington Post will
give a Democrat for Pinocchio's because
he's lying
now if the congenital liar is nothing to
hide then why did he refuse to call the
hearsay whistleblower non whistleblower
in for testimony which he originally
promised to do why did he admit that was
contact with his staff with the
whistleblower now this was a witch-hunt
that has been led totally completely by
him a deranged liar and all his fellow
Democrats that hate Trump every second
every minute every hour of every day now
there's nothing legitimate about this
charade there never has been the Senate
ought never lend any legitimacy to this
corrupt process you got shift his top
investigation witness audition that was
a farce zero due process the accusations
are untrue they have been on untruth the
articles are ridiculous and
unconstitutional and today the
president's legal team beat the living
hell out of the Democrats and they made
a compelling case
what should now happen in short order
that would be acquittal let's take a
look
mentorships words he talked about it
would be wrong if the FBI or the
Department of Justice was starting a
political investigation of the someone's
political opponent and I'm thinking to
myself but isn't that exactly what
happened multiple witnesses who were
called in the House by the House
Democrats testified that the United
States policy towards Ukraine got
stronger under the trump administration
in part largely because of that lethal
aid the issue is not whether a crime is
required the issue is whether abuse of
power is a permissible constitutional
criteria and the answer from the history
is clearly unequivocally note by the way
the question and answer period we're
continuing to monitor because we'll put
it up on the side of your screen you can
take a look and if anything compelling
comes up we'll bring it to you live
while the president's team puts forward
a serious case top Democrats continue to
play their political games and by the
way this is all they've done for three
years they've done not a single thing
for We the People they're supposed to be
public servants earlier today Pelosi's
well friend in the Senate Chuckie
Schumer he actually invited the guy that
is now indicted by the Southern District
of New York for taking of all things a
million dollars from Russia and trying
to hide it another campaign finance
violations he actually invited LED porn
s as a special guest and Lev briefly
became a far left hero because of his
wild allegations against Trump
but unfortunately for Schumer well he is
out on bail for the violations of
campaign finance and trying to hide the
million dollar payment from of all
countries Russia and he couldn't get
into the Senate gallery because he's
wearing an electronic ankle bracelet
this is their star witness this is who
Adam Schiff said believe him but Joanne
hunter did nothing yeah you can't make
this up but it's so sad because it's our
country and they are hurting the country
and they have been for three years
take a look his lawyer called us up and
asked for tickets like many New York and
statue Anson we said you can get tickets
we give them out to the New Yorkers
who've asked I'm not sure Parnas would
be allowed in because of the electronics
around his ankle many many you know
well indicted New Yorkers with ankle
bracelets they're all I ask you to go
they all want to go you know the
Democrats and their BFFs and the mob and
the media they love playing these cheap
political games just like Cavanaugh it's
Cavanaugh 2.0 and I guess they think we
the American people are stupid they
clearly don't like the way we vote they
seem to hate our way of life they seem
to hate our values they seem to hate our
choice for president and they remember
well we've been called irredeemable
deplorable smelly Walmart Trump
supporting shoppers I like Walmart and
by the way they think that it's a bad
thing I guess that we're angry and that
we're bitter and we cling to God
okay I'm guilty I want to cling to God
our Constitution our Bibles and I
believe in our my faith I do I'm guilty
I believe in God yep okay guilty perfect
encapsulation this is a tale now of two
Americas on the one side yab nothing but
24/7 hate accomplishing nothing
never-ending conspiracy theories hoaxes
lies witch hunts on the other side you
got a president keeping every promise
he's made a successful agenda
unprecedented success economically in
foreign policy real tangible results we
even put together a video that perfectly
exemplifies this critical moment in time
two Americas this will be up for grabs
in 279 days you will be the ultimate
jury and you get to shock the world
again take a look we have created 7
million new jobs the average
unemployment rate under my
administration is lower than any
previous administrations listen to this
one in United States history
top Trump's the smart one in there Oh
y'all y'all elitist for you and lead us
with your geography and your maps we
will replace the
after nightmare one of the worst trade
deals ever in history if you vote for
Trump you're the bad guy we also signed
a fantastic new trade agreement with
China they'll follow him to hell or
wherever he's going they don't care
about the facts they don't know about
the facts we have fully rebuilt the
United States military
you could put half of Trump supporters
into what I call the basket of
deplorable --zz America is winning again
and America is thriving again like never
before
see you can at the end of the Isis
Caliphate in Syria Baghdad e &
Associates dead let's see oh we can add
to that yep the number one
state-sponsored terror their leader
Soleimani dead record low unemployment
since 1969 African Americans Asian
Americans Hispanic Americans women in
the workplace youth unemployment
african-american youth unemployment Wow
we're at a critical point 279 days you
have an opportunity to shock the
establishment world again
make no mistake a lot on the line